there's a guy in Canada a dentist named
doc what you met Wayne Gretzky I was a
cab not everybody in Canada is Wayne
Gretzky this this dentist is named
Michael Zook he bought at auction many
years ago John Lennon's tooth that had
been pulled from his head well I guess
that's where you pull a tooth isn't it
weird they took it out his ass or
something that'd be strange not the rare
rectal - now that grants wishes
it was a rotted impacted tooth had been
removed and then someone put it up for
auction he bought it he has announced
that he wants to clone a new John Lennon
from DNA found in the tooth is he
allowed to do that it's his tooth I
guess he can do whatever he wants the
question is can you do that is there
somewhere to do that my favorite part of
this story scientists are skeptical that
he'll be able to pull it off well yeah
you know why because you can't [ __ ]
do it that's why he says most people
would say I'm crazy no so I'm not the
only one [ __ ] you
[Applause]
[ __ ] busted your balls bad it would
be great to say I had a small part in
bringing back one of rock's greatest
stars that would be mind-blowing said
dr. Michael Zook who drops a lot of
[ __ ] acid cut to some giant [ __ ]
John Lennon just I'm going to crush you
oh I'm going to destroy you
bring me your giant Asian women John
Lennon is lonely
just imagine what I could do to you
cuckoo could you
[Music]
you